so he should probably get started so
thanks for sticking around to the last
session of the day and it's been a long
day
document the deposition hope that you
enjoyed the session and find useful
it's about CUDA kernels in C++ couple
words about myself I'm Michael Westen I
work for IVA vision
when we create the next generation of
materiality glasses and we believe that
our technology will eventually replace
all other monitors like just desktops
and mobile phones and we use CUDA mostly
to accelerate algorithms in computer
vision area okay so the SCOOTER is a
platform in the toolkit by nvidia to
create generic algorithms and
applications to run on NVIDIA GPU
devices and that includes support for
different languages it includes some
tools for profiling debugging in
building the code and also a bunch of
libraries made way how many of you have
used cuda or did some basic training
content okay so i'm not going to do a
deep introduction into the programming
but it looks playing on examples so it
should be easy for you to follow it and
you start from a very simple example
basically which will use through the
whole session it's like the hello world
example for cuda problems and that's an
addition of two vectors okay so have a
vector a and vector B and they want to
create a vector C which is an
element-wise sum of the elements of a
and B and the way we do it with CUDA we
create many many what's called CUDA
threads okay this these are not exactly
the threads in the regular sense of the
term but for this session it should work
so create many many CUDA threads each
thread is being assigned certain index
in the output array C which it needs to
calculate and the next property of the
vector addition is that each cell
and calculated independently of the
other cells so all these CUDA feds can
use should run in parallel in the same
time in the wait world to express it in
the CUDA C++ code is like that the first
at Cornell
it's called calling function it's the
code which runs on the GPU it's preceded
with a special keyboard underscore
global but otherwise it looks like a
regular function it has all this in all
these in input parameters the vectors a
p-- AB&C which you want to operate on
and then the first line each thread will
calculate unique index into the race
which needs to work on and skip always
part of block index and thread index
what's important is that each thread in
CUDA will get a unique index to the to
the race
now the second line in a simple addition
of the vectors and B at the end the cell
ID X and the code which runs on CUDA is
Bill it's called the kernel or device
code and the code which runs from CPU is
called the host code or a CPU code so
this example the main is a regular
application in C++ we skip all the
installation parts of the other vectors
and just see special syntax to launch
the kernel on the GPU it uses these
triple angle brackets with some numbers
inside we should also talk about this
right now
but otherwise it looks like a regular
function it passes all the parameters on
pointers to the vectors to the colon
function you can note on the left side
the rest eggs
device and host and keep it in all the
slides so it will be like more easy to
follow which code runs on the CPU in
which quadrants well GPU not so far
looks like a pure C functions and we
said that to talk about CUDA C C++
that's exactly the reason why I'm doing
this talk because in most of the
examples that you find on CUDA
on internet in the books the code is
purely C code and they believe that
using C++ we had many many advantages on
the readability of the code on the type
safety and sometimes even on the
performance of the code so one would
like to depart from the CUDA C
programming and start our journey to
probably a better code this doesn't
let's get back to a first example and
the first question is what if we would
like to sum up floating-point arrays
okay then the C answer would probably
like that we would add another kernel
function a kernel F which takes
parameters as floats but otherwise the
body of the function is exactly the same
as it was before
zip zip as pass solution is much easier
we just make the kernel function
template and now it receives the
pointers and then when we launch the
function the kernel we can either use an
explicit template instance nation like
in first line or we can skip it and then
the parameters will be automatically
deduce the type T will be automatically
used from parameters that look like very
very exciting as a c++ feature but josh
but it just shows that you can use
templates include the kernel codes
basically the same way as you do for
regular programs
another thing that want to address in
first example are these memory pointers
the question is what's the memory that
this pointers are pointing to exactly on
the other system we have a CPU this the
system or a few memory on the host
memory it's regular memory we use in all
in all our services problems and then
each GPU device in have its own memory
also called the global memory or a
device memory and the kernels which run
on GPU can directly access only the
memory which resides on the device and
then what you usually do in CUDA
programs we host allocate the memory on
the device we screw the malach or
similar functions and then we'll copy
the input arrays a and B from
our CPU memory - the HP memory then
watch the function to calculate the
result of actor C and at the end we'll
copy the result back from the GPU to a
CPU and the main problem that approach
is that the type of all the pointers in
the CPU and the GPU is still a row
pointer but the semantics of the pointer
was very different one points the CPU
memory another to appeal to GPU memory
you can build a very simple example
where we launch kernel with pointers to
the local CPU memory and the main
problem is that example is it compiles
but then it fails in runtime and of
course it's it was passed before to fail
as always possible and preferably in
compilation stage and not in the runtime
so what we what to do instead is to
define specific types should device
pointer types device PTR type which
indicates explicitly that this is a
pointer to a device memory and use it in
the corners instead an example how we
can write such a function and find the
class it will be template by the type of
the pointer and now I can make the
constructor of this class private in
order to avoid accidental conversion of
the pointers to device PTR can also know
this underscore school device and host
keywords any function which runs which
is called inside the device code but we
proceeded with the device keyword and if
one want to use the same function in
kernel code and end in hot code should
also add this host
key world and then you can add an
explicit factory function to create a
device pointer from row pointer the
focal videos can also add a global
function which makes a device pointer
from row pointer the whole point is that
now we do it explicitly when we know
that the pointer in hand is a pointer in
the value GPU space
and then to build the mocha print
example of launching the kernel you can
have like this function process assume
that it gets vectors a and B already
initialized at some point in the program
and then in order to launch the kernel
we should do the following first we
would allocate the memory on the device
we could walk and then we'll copy the
memory of the a pointer to the GPU and
connote the special keyboards
could the mem copy host to device it
indicates the device of the memory
copying its from from CPU to the GPU and
we do the same for B and also locate the
memory for C now we can launch a kernel
and use a function make the bus PTR
which converts raw pointer to a device
pointer and then it compiles in the
Comanche : function and and then we want
to copy the result back from the GPU to
CPU so again we would use a copy mm
could the mem copy and now indicates
that the copying from device to host and
may be nice to waste right
the nicer way to try this code would be
it would have some device memory class
which does the installation work for us
then just tell it okay allocate num
number of elements and then a copy
element function does not have to get
that extra parameter with the direction
of the copy it can be deduced from the
parameter types
Duncan G Duncan just launched kernel
these device memory as a parameter and
let it converted to device pointer
automatically you can do something like
that you can create a device memory
class in this case so define the
constructor as a private constructor
just avoid confusion between allocating
and elements and no painting and bytes
and can add static functions to make an
explicit installation of the way on the
memory of
instructor will fill in the memory on
the device and we can add conversional
created the casting operator to cast the
device memory to device PTR type okay
now back to device PTR
so one of the property of the pointer
which you want to maintain is the rules
for the assignment operators so what I
want to be able to copy an interpreter
to the constant pointer but not the way
around and we don't want to assign go in
terms of different types one to another
basically but when to say that want to
allow a copy from from type t1 to type T
only if t1 pointer is convertible to ET
pointer you can write it using type
traits then we say that this copy
constructor is only available if types
of the pointers convertible again it's a
regular C++ code but it just shows that
you can use same template semantics and
headers like type traits in the kernel
code in device code and works fine
another example what might be useful to
use templates in kernel code is to
create some polymorphism so the set of
heaven s : function is basically do add
operation we want to give it an type of
operation in the template parameter so
create a class which is binary opt +
which defines a function call character
which gets two T's and the tauruses a
sum of two T's and then the kernel
template the calling function can now
now get a new template parameter which
is the type of the creation want to
invoke and then the kernel self we
create an instance of the operation up
and and call it instead of explicit a
plus B and once we launch a kernel we
specify the type of the struct of the
operation which you want to use so far
we've seen the use of templates in
static polymorphism next question is how
we do in the line polymorphism in CUDA
so I want to create a binary up
interface Joseph which also also defines
virtual function call ok right or which
takes two values of T type and returns a
tea type in back and now our binary
applause class is an implementation of
the binary up interface and then could
to have a worker function it basically
gets a reference to the interface and
calls the interface by the virtual
function to do the operation and we can
have another column function which uses
that worker function by creating an
instance of binary of plus and and
providing it to the worker function
again it works fine with virtual
functions in CUDA in may be useful in
some cases but there is a very
significant limitation the intention is
that the can't pass classes with virtual
functions from the CPU code to the GPU
code as is not the problem because a
business logic used resides on CPU code
the CPU part of the code is one to
decide which operation want to invoke on
the GPU either it's ad or other type of
operations and we can try to solve it in
a couple of ways this one way is to add
back this template parameter to the
column function and pass it as a
template parameter but we want the
kernel and it works but then it misses
the point a bit as if they already have
operation s template parameter because
just propagate is a template parameter
and use and use the static static
selection of the functions as we did
before in this case there's not much use
on which value to use virtual functions
in kernel code what we would like to do
instead is to have a kernel function to
get a pointer to an interface to
implementation of binary up interface
and somehow want to create it on the CPU
code and pass a pointer to it to the
kernel
so tomato want on first to allocate the
memory on a GPU from sea view of the
property size T then inside the GPU code
we can access this memory and initialize
it to valid object of type T and now in
this app you part have a valid pointer
to it the object on GPU which you can
use and and pass to a kernel function
while we launch it let's let's see how
this can be implemented you can add a
new class which is a device object it
will use the device memory class which
you've seen before in the constructor to
first allocate one element using the
facilities of the device memory class
now the more interesting part is how we
initialize the object on the GPU
basically we want to create a kernel
function and the calling functions the
global functions chain box from CPU
there must be freestanding functions
they can't be member functions in the
class so don't need the only way to do
some encapsulation is to use a namespace
okay so in this case we create a kernel
function allocate objects we should get
a pointer to some memory on the GPU
device and then arguments to initialize
the object then we use a regular
placement operator new to initialize the
object in place on the device and from a
CPU code the constructor of dev object
it would launch a single instance of
allocate object just need a signal could
thread to do the work and we are done
and have add a class T on the GPU GPU
memory which is properly initialized
with all parameters but the way we also
note that the parameters to allocate
object are passed by value in number
reference and we can't pass argument by
reference from CPU to GPU in the
references in different different
neighbor spaces and then to use it in
natural way from the from CPU code you
can just add also a casting operator
from device object
- device pointer and then it completes
the example of course because also add
it release a wrist functional instructor
- device object which we'll call also a
special kernel function to call the
destructor on the device side and then
the memory is released in the destructor
of the DMM of the noble class so we are
done the case we've seen the static
polymorphism next stop is new delete
functions basically the section is a
shortest in all the slides says that you
can use malloc free and new delete
functions in kernel code it works as
expected it allocates memory or the
object in the device device memory space
I'm not sure that you want to always use
it but at least it's available and it
works as expected
ok next feature of C++ which you want to
explore how to use it in in color code
alum the functions the very simple
example is to create a lambda function
inside the kernel function which will do
the post operation for us on parameters
a and B so this example it's a static
lambda and then we invoke it as we would
do with the regular C++ code and it
works also all the rules to capture the
lambdas applying on a GPU code and the
theater lambda which captures a state in
these cases index and pointers to a and
B and that's the calculation of the sum
inside see that the most exciting news
case for lambdas is that we can pass
lambdas between the CPU and the GPU and
that's supported by Kudo compiler so we
can add a template type operation to our
SQL no signature and then we get the OP
parameter in the kernel function it will
just call it as regular second lambda
function and then lambda itself is
defined in main and you should note the
special key world underscore underscore
device
which means that but this is that's a
lambda which is created in the CPU but
it can run in GPU it also requires to
add a special computation flag which
supports extended lambda but otherwise
it works like most most irregular
because they're Google general lambdas
is very useful to pass logic from a CPU
to GPU in different way the question is
have read this lambda which crosses the
border between the CPU and GPU we send
it the callin function and the question
is what can be captured as part of
CAPTCHA parameters of this lambda one
exception you can do is and it comes as
no surprise we can't capture any
parameters inside lambda by reference
and the game is because you can't
reference any memory only CPU and pass
it to GPU as is so just fail in runtime
this example you try to capture some
values the reference then it fails
already in copulation time is expected
the more interesting problem is
capturing of this pointer let's see an
example of how it looks like so now
operation to sum up two vectors is much
more complicated we want to add the
vector a vector B but also add some
constant number I do each one of the
elements so create structure up which it
presents the operation that you want to
apply on the cool down it's towards its
doors that I integer inside and then you
can add an apply function which you
create basically a lamp inside you
capture I by this pointer and we can
launch the kernel from the apply
function the problem is this code
compiles but then it fails in runtime
because this is scheduled the pointer in
the solution is to use a value capturing
semantics for this just use
starve this and this is being captured
my value the value has been copied
inside said the lambda and then it works
fine but still think that this code has
a problem from design perspective that
is that the start-up is too complicated
all we wanted it to be is to represent a
simple addition operation of two numbers
and in in AI but instead of that it has
this apply function which knows a
certain Colonel exists and it tries to
launch it and it should be much easier
you'd like it to be something like that
you'd like the start-up to be factory
which creates a function for us and then
want to somehow use it when we launch
the kernel function first attempt would
be just to get the lambda out of the
abstract and send it to the GPU into GPU
code similar structure which works fine
on the regular ship
there goes pass pass code but it doesn't
compile on CUDA and get a compilation
error that the make up function which
created the lambda can have auto return
type so need to specify in a specific
zone type in this case okay so can tribe
try to return a function which gets to
in return an int and we know that lambda
can be converted to a function but then
there's a problem but you can't pass the
stool function to the kernel and also
it's not very surprising as odd as we
said that only functions which run on
GPU should have this device keyboard
inside and there's no reason why I stood
function would have one but instead we
can use an envy envy stood function
which is provided in header and be
functional as part of CUDA package by
Nvidia but now the case is even worse as
this compiles but then it fails in
runtime and there
we go on and read and read the
documentation it says the cone can't
pass and we stood function is the
parameter to : function so it's a bit of
a mix in this case so the only solution
that I found 20 new dope lead this
example is to pass the whole structure
up as the parameter to the to the CUDA
kernel and then to create the lambda
inside the kernel function and return it
as an as an bastogne function and then
finally works it's less beauty as
beautiful from design point of view then
what we intended it to be
but still it's useful and it works
because we've seen issues on the lambdas
and the canvas tool function but the
question is are all these zero of head
obstructions and we expect Tom Seaver
stars features and maybe you can run
some performance tests to compare like
before and after it's not always good
solution is it's hard to distinguish
distinguish between a real overhead
caused by the code change and between
just random fluctuations on a small time
but another solution which becomes very
popular and even be hardly mentioned it
is to use for example the compiler
Explorer to compare the code before and
after in pretty recently could support
was added to compile the exporter and
you can now paste our code and see make
sure for example that the handcrafted C
style code produces the same same binder
exactly as you'll get with all the
lambdas and functions and so on that's a
great tool to make sure that all
obstructions are not only beautiful but
doesn't hurt the performance in any way
and another tool you can use it's a good
object amp it
part of the CUDA package so in this case
I give it the object file which is the
result of completion of the CUDA file
and that sa SS parameter which means
that you want to get the binary of the
assembly print it out and again can use
it and compare the function before the
C++ presentation and after and see that
it's the same performance exactly it's
the same binary code so during the test
they see the static polymorphism is free
lambdas are also free I was also
surprised to see that example with the
hood function also did not produce any
overhead and like all the only use of
function was optimized by the compiler I
believe in some cases okay but not big
case as we know that at least on the
regular integrity versus programs the
user function can have some overhead but
in my examples it was also fine just to
mention some other types of features
that you can use in kernel code we've
seen the use of auto Const experts
expert functions can be used a range
based loop iteration and also our value
semantics move semantics it's all
applicable in the CUDA code in same way
as it is in the CPU code the only
exception to the rule are the exceptions
and it's very similar to what happens
probably be embedded there's a better
use of C++ the exceptions are not
supported at least not in the current
format it might be that you know a
couple of standards from now you have a
new support for exceptions if you'll be
more appropriate to run all the beta
devices and on the GPU for now we can't
use exceptions in the kernel code and a
couple of of kudos specific examples
which is related to C++ so first example
have this kernel that needs to iterate
over some array
and then want to use the pragma on all
feature to get better performance of
this Coronel but the way I've seen some
examples were unrolling the loop in the
CUDA code it really makes a big change
you see performance is much better and
it's miserable but the question is what
was the put as a parameter to per
control and until the recent versions it
had only put a hard-coded number in this
place and it can be appropriated some
cases but maybe not and in recent
versions of CUDA you can basically use
any value which can be deducted in the
compile time so it can be this example
you can use a constructor function which
combines some template parameter with
constant number and as long as we can as
a compiler could use this value in
compiled time it will do the appropriate
unroll parameter and hope that our code
will run faster another feature which is
also specific to the CUDA is a rant
incorporation of the CUDA code so the
cuda library has some facilities to load
basically could the functions and
compile them and upload them to the
device dynamically is opposite to a
special syntax which we've seen so far
and it's much more similar to open sale
if you're familiar with that some of the
entities some advantages of using the
rantin compilation on the regular
compilation first is that you don't need
to have a special go-to compiler they
just compile the application with any
compiler that you use and then just
linked with CUDA libraries which are C
libraries which allow you to upload the
code to device and do the compilation
and do all the stuff that the reason
that may be useful to do the Ratan
compilation is to tune the compilation
flex so table example might be tuning
and architecture
but basically in run time you can look
at the exact device that you have in
hand and and build the completion flags
to be optimized for this device now
that's the use case Jeff which i think
is very interesting and small related to
C++ is that in if in the source code of
C++ have some template functions then we
can specify the template parameters in
runtime with that random population code
so an example of how this can be useful
okay so again have some process kernel
which runs on the GPU and we want to use
the fragment roll to make it run faster
and we don't know the number of layers
in this example in advance we want to
get it as a template parameter to our
current function but the problem is that
this number of layers is calculated in
the main program dynamically and you
can't know it in the compile time
because how do we pass an int as
definite parameter it's one solution is
to create some some proxy function we
should just do and if we switch on all
the possible values for the layers and
we've called appropriate technical
sector it's it's not very nice piece of
code it also requires us to know in
advance all the possible values of
layers also it means that all the
versions of the process function on CUDA
will be compiled and become a part of
our binary and when we use the dynamic
the compile time the only compilation of
the color code you can basically specify
all the parameters in the compile time
and I'm not going over the exact
examples of how you do it you can find
the good examples on internet on in the
cuda documentation but basically a
function for example which gives you the
suppose first name of the template which
we needs to which you need to use from
the deputy parameter and other functions
to register template parameters and then
use them when you launch the current
function because eventually started from
C programming and enriched start start
using C++ in CUDA kernels know a couple
of links to finish MS so one is a github
repository where we can find all these
examples in more details in it's not
very complete it's mostly like
filtration of special features that you
can do on CUDA and links to one in the
blog post by Nvidia in the CUDA 8
version there are many features which
were added to the Super's for support
and you can read it it's very nice even
article and also you want to look at the
GPU programming we see pass pass the
take a look at the cocoa library
he doesn't target only the nvidia
platform but basically all the other HPC
is PC platforms questions yes
talked about what examples where we want
to build your own kernels and to launch
it own device and like shows which which
which of so she passed pass you can use
risky trust does use lambdas as a
parameters to its functions it has a
certain set of operators level to use it
in many cases but if you want to write
your own code of code then you may want
to use some superstars features visit
yeah
the question is the most difference
which we could and OpenCL so basically
OpenCL is an open standard and for
NVIDIA devices its implemented on top of
CUDA
I believe that you can some cases you
can gain more control on your code with
CUDA as basically its closest to the
platform as it gets there's some
parameters it's consumed in CUDA and
some special functions which deals with
memory consistency and caching and so on
which she believed not exist in a more
general API so open sale but it's about
in the same level if you think about a
GPU you feel programming okay thank you
[Applause]